He continued war against a 79 year old infectious
disease doctor who has worked for six presidents
continues.
I'm talking about Dr. Anthony Foushee continues
to be the target of protesters.
Remember a couple of weeks ago, a chant of
fire.
Foushee broke out at one of these reopened
protests.
Here's the audio and video reminder of that.
Well, it's getting even worse.
They're going from fire foushee now to signs
that say hang foushee, hang foushee.
Those have started to pop pop up at protests.
Here's one from a Long Island, New York protest
over the weekend which says Hang foushee,
hang gates, open up all our states.
Very poetic, very nice rhyming, but completely
horrifying.
Hang Gates, of course, refers to Bill Gates,
who's donating huge sums of his own money
to find a vaccine.
He's being regularly attacked for it.
He's at the center of multiple conspiracy
theories, arguing that his intentions are
actually nefarious.
Will there actually be any accountability
for the conspiracy theorists that have spent
months spreading this nonsense?
Because this is a complete backslide from
just basic enlightenment values.
Now, I want to be careful because some of
these enlightened centrists and so-called
classical liberals, they love to fetishize
talking about enlightenment values.
And then they argue wildly that the left on
Twitter is falling back from enlightenment
values by trying to do things to prevent hate
speech or whatever.
We don't do that here.
OK.
I don't know the last time I mentioned enlightenment
values.
This is not something I've discussed that
much before.
But the anti-science cesspool that has become
the corona virus protests.
It actually is a fight against basic enlightenment
values of rationalist philosophy.
Our respective science not fetishizing science,
just a respect for the scientific process
and what it provides us respect of the law.
Importantly, so much of what we now take for
granted.
Consider that the terrorists don't have to
attack us anymore.
Why would they?
We are destroying ourselves from the inside
as this battle has been created between those
who understand and respect the scientific
process and who understand what is an expert.
This is not about phony experts, but actually
the difference between Dr. Anthony Foushee
and some guy on the internet with a blog.
Right.
And those who peddle conspiracies and mass
gather believe that they know better than
actual doctors.
This is not the crisis of expertise, which
is something I've not been shy about covering.
Imagine the same people rightly criticizing
the signs and the chants of death to America
elsewhere in the world.
They are the same ones who chant Fire foushee
and hold up signs that say Hang Foushee, we're
doing the job of the terrorists for them.
I would even go further when it comes to the
country being united against the common enemy.
After 9/11, Americans were, by and large,
briefly united.
Very united.
It didn't last that long because George W.
Bush turned 9/11 into a war against Iraq,
which had nothing to do with 9/11 at all.
But there was a period there, the end of 2001
when George W. Bush went to the rubble at
Ground Zero.
His approval rating spiked.
I think it was 86 or even 90 percent.
In late 2001.
And the country was united.
This could have happened with coronavirus.
I've said it before.
If on March 5th, Trump makes an FDR like speech,
I'm not endorsing everything FDR did.
OK, so before you even start sending me messages
about that, but an FDR like speech where he
speaks to the nation and says we have difficult
times ahead.
We do.
The economics are going to be tough for a
little while, but we must come together.
We need stay at home from 50 governors for
60 days.
You know, maybe at that time it would've been
30 and then it ends up getting extended for
30.
We're going to come out on the other side.
We are going to come out with few deaths.
We will start to reopen and rebuild.
That ship sailed.
But with it also sailed, the administration
may be presiding over a rational reaction.
Instead, we've seen Donald Trump sort of coyly
says support the protesters, drawing a line
in the sand, separating his view from that
of the scientists, criticizing everybody under
the sun about his own mishandling from Obama
to governors to Democrats, whoever else, while
lying about testing and everything else.
This doesn't bode well for our future.
Other countries are realizing it.
I told you that their laughter has mostly
turned to horror and pity at this point.
And I don't know how we dig out
of it.
My friends, I really don't.